[موسيقى]
ميسي معجب بصوره بايرن ميونخ مبابي يدفع
جريزمان للاعتزال ورساله تلغي مباراه
ايطاليا وانجلترا هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
يبدو ان اليوم ميسي سيستمر في استفزاز
جماهير فريقه سان جيرمان فبعد تجنبه
القائد التحيه على المشجعين عقب خساره
افريقيا امام النجم الارجنتيني بعمل اعجاب
لصوره على حساب بايرن ميونخ الرسمي في
موقع انستغرام الجماهير الفرنسيه لم تهضم
هذا التصرف خاصه وان فريقها قد ودع منافسه
دوري الابطال على يد الفريق الالماني
كيليان مبابي بعمر الرابعه والعشرين سيكون
قائدا لمنتخب فرنسا خبر احبط زميله في
الفريق اطول غريزمان الذي يعده هو الاقدم
والاجدر بحمل اشاره القياده وهذا بحسب
محبي نجم اتلتيكو مدريد الذي بدا رحلته مع
ديوك عام 2014
وبحسب تقارير عالميه فرنسيه فان جريزمان
يفكر جديا في اعتزال اللاعب دوليا بعد
قرار المدرب ديدي ديشون
نجم برشلونه السابق جيرارد بيكي لا يزال
يثروا الجدل عبر منصه التويتش وهذه المره
كشف بك عن خبر وخطط اعتزال لزميله السابق
في نادي برشلونه بوينت عن طريق الخطا في
برنامج كينج ليج بين اعتزاله اليوم الخميس
ليس هذا فقط فالاضافه بان اعلان الاعتزال
سوف يكون في ملعبي كامب نو
[موسيقى]